bonjour merci de nous rejoindre en
direct du Sénat maintenant ou la réforme
territoriale arrive en examen devant la
Haute Assemblée d'abord en commission
cet après-midi puisque vous allez
pouvoir suivre sur notre antenne deux
auditions d'abord celle du ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard Cazeneuve qui va
être entendu par la commission des lois
suivi d'une audition cette fois en
différé celle d'Allah Rousset et de
l'ensemble des présidents des régions en
françaises actuelles ils seront entendus
par les sénateurs toujours de la
commission des lois une audition qui est
aussi ouverte à d'autres sénateurs des
autres commissions donc la réforme
territoriale qui arrivera dans
l'hémicycle au Sénat à partir du 1er
juillet on verra avec les deux sénateurs
qui sont présents sur ce plateau d'abord
le Parti socialiste sénateur des
Hauts-de-Seine bonjour merci d'être avec
nous et puis
Eric deliger sénateur
UMP du Loiret donc on verra combien de
jours durera au Sénat cette discussion
autour de la réforme territoriale 1er
juillet 2 juillet peut-être trois
juillet on verra si les débats sont
agités mais on a déjà vu cet après-midi
avec l'audition des présidents de région
mais qui avait beaucoup de questions des
sénateurs pas mal d'inquiétude quand
même Philippe Katan Bax si bien qu'on
peut se demander aujourd'hui si cette
réforme sera votée par le Sénat c'est
toujours une question la majorité au
Sénat et
faible puisque à 5 de 5 sièges avant
majorité pour la gauche donc le débat va
avoir lieu et on verra à l'issue des
débats s'il y a une majorité sur ce
texte sur les métropoles il y avait eu
les mêmes remarques et puis à la fin le
texte sur la métropole a été voté par le
Sénat donc je crois que le texte va être
amendé par le Sénat va être modifié pour
tenir compte des avis des différents
groupes des remontées aussi du terrain
et nous travaillons pour qu'à la fin de
ces débats le texte trouve bien une
majorité au Sénat je crois qu'il est
important que le Sénat qui représente
les collectivités saisissent de ce texte
et qui est assez de sens de
responsabilité pour qu'un texte puisse
être voté au Sénat à l'issue de débats
imprimer sa patte sur cette réforme
territoriale que ce soit uniquement
l'Assemblée nationale qui puisse passer
ses amendements Eric de Ligier pourquoi
sur cette réforme territoriale dont on
parle depuis si longtemps il y a
tellement eu de rapports ici au Sénat et
bien finalement la gauche et à droite ne
pourrait pas arriver à se mettre
d'accord sur une position commune
effectivement ça a été très difficile
mais je vous rappelle qu'il a quand même
été voté un texte majeur qui était le
conseiller territorial et la suppression
de la clause de compétences générale et
que l'on revient avec la réimplantation
bientôt de la clause de compétence
générale qui va être supprimé puisque le
président de la République a demandé de
la supprimer et puis qu'on est en train
peut-être de préparer un conseiller
territorial à l'envers après la loi dont
on va discuter dans quelques jours alors
effectivement cette loi
pourquoi avoir perdu deux ans et avoir
perdu autant d'argent sur un sujet qui
aurait pu déjà peut-être être traité en
grande partie voire améliorer et amender
alors là on a un texte on sait pas très
bien comment il va sortir on sait tout
juste comment il va rentrer puisque hier
le texte que l'on avait en sous-main
n'est pas tout à fait le texte qui est
sorti aujourd'hui du du Conseil des
ministres sur les dates etc et puis il y
a eu des élections alors effectivement
il a été annoncé du Conseil des
ministres ce matin que les élections
régionales et départementales seront
normalement organisés en décembre 2015
qui semble un peu près normal Eric de
Ligier quand même il faut un délai d'un
an selon la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnelle entre
la réforme et puis l'organisation de
nouvelles élections
chaise 2015 de 2017 maintenant d'État
fin 2015 donc c'est quand même une
ambiance un peu particulière donc qui va
négocier qui va nécessiter quelques
négociations autour d'amendement le
texte qui va rentrer va certainement pas
être voté donc il va probablement être
beaucoup modifié pour pouvoir être voté
par une majorité au Sénat alors
on va de groupe socialiste au Sénat à
Philippe katenbach elle est 3 ministres
qui sont venus présenter cette réforme
devant votre groupe Bernard Cazeneuve le
ministre de l'intérieur mais également
Marylise le branchu et André valini pour
la réforme territoriale le dit leur
audition devant votre groupe a duré très
très longtemps donc ça veut dire qu'il y
avait beaucoup de questions beaucoup
d'inquiétudes aussi chez les sénateurs
socialistes pour clarifier le débat il y
a deux textes qui vont être débattus
d'abord au sein d'un peu à l'Assemblée
un premier texte et c'est le premier qui
va être examiné le 1er juillet concerne
la carte des régions et le décalage des
élections pour les élections cantonales
et régionales et un deuxième texte qui
va venir il y a un deuxième texte qui va
arriver juste derrière qui lui va
traiter des compétences puisqu'on va
renforcer les compétences des régions
voilà donc il y a deux textes sont
différents un premier sur la carte et la
date des élections et un deuxième sur
les compétences le débat au sein du
groupe socialiste a principalement porté
sur l'avenir des conseils départementaux
puisque c'est vrai qu'il y a
quelques-uns notamment dans les
départements ruraux sur l'avenir de ce
conseil départemental autant dans les
métropoles et moi je suis élu d'une
grande métropole à l'Île-de-France et la
région parisienne il y a pas vraiment de
débattre tout le monde comprend qu'il
faut évoluer on crée les métropoles
qu'on supprime les départements c'est la
même chose il y a ces crânes dans les
départements héros et je crois que le
gouvernement est déjà décalé la mise en
application de la suppression des
départements en 2020 mais que la porte
reste ouverte à une évolution peut-être
qu'il pourra voir il va avoir dans
chaque département un conseil regroupant
des représentants des intercommunalités
qui pourraient gérer les questions
sociales je crois que sur ce sujet des
départements les choses ne sont pas
encore complètement finalisées et dans
tous les cas et c'est la position du
groupe socialiste il faudra trouver une
solution une organisation un cadre de
décision et de concertation pour les
discussions concernant les départements
ruraux et les zones rurales qui se
posent ici au Sénat mais aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale j'imagine c'est
d'avoir le découpage des régions on va
en parler en premier lieu puis après
effectivement le transfert des
compétences et quid des départements et
puis aussi de l'organisation au niveau
des intercommunalités alors déjà si on
prend la refonte des régions française a
priori on partirait sur 12 à 14 régions
on a entendu Manuel Valls dire que un
département ne pourra pas exercer son
droit de sortir si on peut dire du d'une
région mais qu'en revanche il pourrait y
avoir des glissements d'une région à une
autre est-ce que ça ça vous va comme
système Eric de Ligier j'aurais aimé
qu'effectivement certains départements
qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans leur
futur région puisse avoir un droit
d'option c'était d'ailleurs ce qui avait
été dit il y a 15 jours à peu près et
puis ça a duré 24 heures
finalement j'étais quand même une des
options qui avait été prévue par le
premier ministre le soir et le lendemain
matin lors de tous les départements vont
vouloir changer de région le problème
c'est que je vous rappelle quand même
que à l'origine le Parti socialiste qui
est au pouvoir actuellement avait
toujours dit il faut d'abord débattre
des compétences avant de avant de
débattre de l'organisation et on reprend
il y a deux textes qui ont été
après les compétences je rappelle aussi
que le le fondement c'était quand même
et la Cour des comptes l'a rappelé ce
matin c'était comment faire des
économies au niveau des collectivités je
rappelle qu'il y a pas un mot sur les
économies dans le préambule et que les
économies qui sont le 25 milliards selon
Monsieur valini il y a 3 jours il a
déclaré que finalement ça coûterait plus
cher au départ de réorganiser les
territoires donc c'est quand même
important alors aujourd'hui si on peut
arriver à remarier les régions
différemment que ce qui a été proposé
dans le texte initial c'est déjà une
avancée alors justement je vous propose
d'écouter Philippe catallebach avant de
réagir et de répondre à Éric deliger
Didier Migaud le président de la Cour
des comptes il s'est exprimé justement
sur cette réforme territoriale est-ce
que ça va ou non permettre des économies
on écoute la réponse de Didier Migaud
S c'est une clarification des
compétences entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales à partir de
constat de doublons
et là c'est susceptible effectivement si
c'est doublons sont supprimés
d'entraîner des économies internes il
faut aussi non seulement clarifier les
compétences entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales mais
également clarifier les compétences
entre les collectivités territoriales
elles-mêmes et nous avons toujours
promener en ce qui concerne la Cour des
comptes la fin de la clause de
compétences générales voilà la fin la
cause compétence de compétences générale
comme dit Didier simplification ça c'est
aussi un des objectifs qui affiché dans
le préambule du projet loi affiché par
le gouvernement est-ce que ça va
vraiment être une grosse simplification
cette réforme des régions françaises je
crois la volonté de faire des économies
c'est certain mais il y a aussi la
volonté de mieux organiser la
gouvernance des territoires pour
qu'ensuite les services rendus à la
population soit de meilleure qualité
qu'on modernise le pays et qu'on
accompagne le redressement du pays les
régions à quel terme les régions combien
de temps combien de temps ça va mettre
pour se mettre mis en place il va
falloir choisir une capitale pour chaque
raison
ça se fait pas bien sûr du jour au
lendemain l'idée c'est de renforcer la
région comme étant vraiment l'acteur
principal en matière de développement
économique en renforçant les compétences
de la région pour aider accompagner les
entreprises
en matière d'aide entreprises en matière
de formation en matière de transport en
matière d'aménagement donc la région va
jouer demain un rôle beaucoup plus fort
en matière de développement économique
c'est la volonté de ce texte et je crois
qu'il est important qu'on puisse
renforcer nos régions en France et en
faire vraiment des locomotives pour
renforcer notre économie et assurer une
plus grande compatibilité justement on
n'a pas quand même tout le détail encore
de ces transfert de compétences qui vont
pouvoir renforcer les régions et en
faire des véritables moteurs économiques
un moteur économique c'était aussi le
terme employé ce matin par par le
gouvernement mais sans ressource
financière supplémentaires est-ce que ça
c'est possible et rigoler moi je veux
bien écouter tout ce que l'on raconte en
ce moment nous nous sommes des ruraux
enfin 80%
80% des départements sont ruraux à part
les 10 ou 12 qui ont une capitale si
j'ose dire une vraie capitale une
métropole et puis bien sûr la région
parisienne et le Bassin parisien mais
tout le reste sont des ruraux quand
j'entends qu'on va simplifier qu'on va
faire de la proximité qu'on va mieux
gérer en mettant une région qui va faire
500 km de long qui va s'éloigner des
citoyens où il n'y aura plus le relais
départemental puisque c'est quand même
ce qui est prévu enfin de processus
c'est totalement impossible comment vous
allez gérer le social comment vous allez
gérer les pompiers
vous aurez des régions assez fortes et
plus puissantes on est tous d'accord
pour des régions plus fortes et plus
puissantes mais je vous rappelle que le
rapport que l'on a voté à l'unanimité à
part je crois une personne mais qui
était un rapport qui a été fait par
Monsieur Raffarin et notre collègue
socialiste
le rapport disait il y a deux volets il
y a un volet qui est de réduire le
nombre de régions on est tous d'accord
et il y a un deuxième volet qui est
indispensable c'est d'avoir des
départements qui soient forts et qui
soit sur le terrain or le Premier
ministre a dit je retiens le rapport
gratiné Raffarin c'est le rapport
cratère mais il ne parle plus des
départements il parle que des régions
donc ça ne fonctionne pas donc moi je
suis d'accord pour supprimer une partie
des régions pour en réduire le nombre et
je suis d'accord
pour déduire par deux le nombre de
départements le nombre de parlementaires
aussi ça me dérange pas donc le
millefeuille il y a des feuilles et il y
a de la crème pâtissière au milieu la
crème pâtissière c'est toutes
l'épaisseur de la complexité du nombre
de collectivité à chaque niveau de
strates mais il faut les simplifier
mieux les organiser des strates on est
en train de d'agrandir parce que mon
collègue est de la région Île-de-France
nous on est des ruraux quand on parle
des communautés de communes qu'on va
passer à 20000 pour essayer de créer un
simili département à l'avenir ça ne
fonctionne pas enfin il faut venir voir
sur le terrain comment les choses
s'équilibrent aujourd'hui donc on va
être obligé de recréer des départements
là où on les aura supprimés enfin
conseil départemental Sana pas de sens
il faut avoir une réforme globale et
définir les compétences avant de
s'amuser à faire du charcutage du
découpage
on commence par les régions on parle en
même temps des compétences puisque les
deux textes ont été examinés ce matin
quand c'est des ministres ils seront vus
par le Sénat très rapidement il y a la
région qui va jouer un rôle central et
majeur et c'est je crois important et
nous sommes d'accord tant mieux et dans
un deuxième temps on reparlera des
départements en zone rurale puisque tout
ça est décalé à 2020 ça laisse le temps
de travailler à la meilleure manière
d'organiser une gouvernance
qui inquiète les élus socialistes ici au
Sénat ils sont c'est le sort des
départements et tous ceux qui sont
présidents de conseil généraux conseils
ou conseiller généraux tout court ils
ont envie de savoir un petit peu
les départements sur les
intercommunalités qui vont être mises en
place avec ces vrais ce seuil de 20000
habitants ce qui donnera des
intercommunalités qui seront assez
fortes même dans les zones rurales et
ensuite il faudra arriver à les faire
travailler ensemble à créer des
fédérations d'intercommunalité sur des
projets sur des organisations sur de la
solidarité je crois qu'on va comme ça
recréer une assemblée qui pourra décider
dans la proximité un échelon qui soit
proche du terrain voilà on va recréer un
conseil général bon mais le problème
c'est pas les élus qui sont inquiets
c'est pas grave que les élus soient
inquiets bon ça change ça tourne la
problématique ce sont les salariés les
fonctionnaires territoriaux il y en a
quand même 290 000 on leur a dit il y a
pas longtemps 202 chacun les
départements vécus on supprime vos
employeurs et puis on leur a dit bah non
ça va être en 2015 puis en 2016 2017
puis 2015
j'ai 2600 personnes qui travaillent au
Conseil Général du Loiret et 10000
personnes qui dépendent au quotidien du
travail du Conseil général il se pose il
se pose la question aujourd'hui quelle
est notre avenir on nous trimbale de
façon qu'il se pose tellement anormale
mais je crois qu'il faut les rassurer
par exemple dans le test qui va arriver
les collèges vont être transférés des
départements aux régions comme ça ça
donnera en plus à la région des
facilités pour gérer à la fois les
lycées et les collèges moi je trouve ça
assez cohérent et assez intelligent mais
les personnels des conseils généraux qui
travaillaient dans les collèges vont
être transférés aux régions et la seule
chose qui va changer pour eux c'est leur
fiche de paye ça ne sera plus la fiche
de paye du Conseil Général du Loiret
mais celle de la future région qui en
actuelle région Centre donc il y a pas
de difficulté pour les personnel je
crois que vouloir affolez des personnels
bien sûr c'est pour ça que je cherche
c'est pour ça que je cherche à les
rassurer il y aura pas de conséquences
sur l'emploi il y aura pas de
conséquences sur les salaires il y aura
pas de conséquences sur la manière de
travailler il y aura des transferts de
service ça c'est déjà fait par le passé
lorsqu'on a créé les intercommunalités
ça c'est déjà fait lorsque l'État a
décentralisé des services donc tout ça
est connu et ce il y a pas d'inquiétude
à avoir parce que tout va être organisé
de manière transparente et sans aucun
risque pour les salariés je comprends
qu'ils sont inquiets mais je profite de
l'antenne pour les rassurer moi je les
rassure toute la longueur de journée
puisque vous vous les inquiétez le
Premier ministre les inquiète je suis
désolé il faut vivre avec eux et
entendre ce qu'il dit ils sont paniqués
pour un certain nombre surtout dans les
Services Support c'est bien évident
alors bien sûr dans les collèges celui
qui travaille dans un collège que son
patron soit le département ou la région
ça changera quand même parce que moi la
région aujourd'hui on a 57 collèges que
ça augmente les coûts forcément et que
ça devrait rassurer les personnels
puisque justement les harmonisations se
faisant par le haut personne ne sera
perdant je crois que dans ce que vous
dites ce qui est intéressant c'est pour
les personnes
qui se pose dans le transfert des
compétences et maintenant qui à terme va
gérer les prestations sociales je pense
notamment au RSA certains pointent du
doigt l'idée d'une recentralisation
l'État qui reprendrait en charge en main
toutes ces prestations sociales est-ce
que là aussi on va y voir un petit peu
plus clair pour le moment c'est en débat
et on a le temps puisque tout ça est
reporté à 2020 donc il va y avoir une
loi qui va être votée qui va transférer
des compétences des départements vers
les régions les collèges les routes donc
ça ça va se régler rapidement et ensuite
pour les compétences sociales elles vont
continuer à être exercées par les
départements je rappelle qu'il y aura
bien des élections pour les conseils
départementaux en décembre 2015 tant
qu'il y aura bien il y aura bien des
conseils départementaux qui vont être
élus qui vont continuer qui vont on va
voter pour des sélections
départementales et on sans savoir si à
terme dans un deux trois quatre cinq ans
c'est des départements supprimer à mon
délire pour 5 ans c'est quand même un
mandat respectable ils auront à gérer
toutes les politiques sociales et en
effet nous aurons à travailler nous
parlementaires avec les locaux pour
préparer cette transition et je l'ai dit
moi je crois que il faut aller vers une
forme d'organisation sur les territoires
ruraux pour maintenir cette proximité et
qu'il faudra pour se faire à mon sens
s'appuyer sur les intercommunités qui
vont être mises en place donc il reste
en effet d'ici 2020 des choses à
construire des choix arbitrer et je ne
pense pas que tout soit bouclé
aujourd'hui loin de là donc n'essayons
pas d'affoler et les personnels et les
populations l'objectif de cette loi je
le répète c'est de faire des économies
certes bien sûr mais au-delà c'est
d'assurer un meilleur service public une
meilleure proximité une meilleure
efficacité pour ben voilà construire la
France du 21e siècle c'est ça l'enjeu
c'est pas de rester toujours regarder le
rétroviseur sur c'est vrai des choses
qu'on a fait par le passé voilà la carte
de France doit évoluer l'organisation
doit évoluer la gouvernance doit évoluer
c'est à nous maintenant parlementaire à
faire les meilleurs propositions en
écoutant les élus locaux c'est ce que
fait d'ailleurs la Commission
à l'instant à l'instant le président de
région était entendu ce qu'on va pouvoir
suivre sur notre antenne puisque la
commission des lois dans dans quelques
minutes là on attend le ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard Cazeneuve donc il va
venir s'exprimer devant la Commission de
loi du Sénat et puis les sénateurs
pourront également l'interroger et puis
après l'audition de du ministre de
l'intérieur on aura l'audition des
présidents de région qui ont été reçus
cet après-midi aussi par par la
commission des lois donc on va pouvoir
écouter les inquiétudes et les envies
aussi des uns et des autres deux
secteurs à retravailler peut-être c'est
la Picardie champagne et puis toute la
région Centre Ouest et Loire donc là il
y a sûrement des modifications à
apporter sur les compétences moi j'ai
entendu des présents de région qui était
quand même favorables à cette évolution
des compétences qui renforcent les
régions sur la date des élections en cas
des élections on voit bien on voit bien
qu'elle a des élections doit être portée
puisque tout sera ne sera pas en place
et en mars
on va pouvoir assister au Sénat à partir
du 1er juillet en séance dans
l'hémicycles ça va être quoi ça va être
une bataille entre les présidents de
départements de région pour savoir qui
va accueillir
et que il tourne mieux c'est bien sur le
plan du territoire qu'au plan national
la problématique c'est qu'on est en
train de mettre en place un machin
extrêmement compliqué la preuve c'est
qu'on va faire des élections
départementales la réforme territoriale
que vous avez pas suivi 2015 avec un
binôme qui va durer quatre ans on va
élire un binôme sur des nouveaux
territoires qui est un nouvel mode
d'élection
sur la première fois et on va leur dire
voilà on vous donne les clés du
département et votre objectif c'est de
fermer à clé et d'éteindre la lumière
donc il faut quand même être un peu plus
réaliste que vous ces choses là et de
regarder comment cela fonctionne
aujourd'hui sur le plan social notamment
et vous l'avez souligné c'est impossible
de donner le plan social quand on
connaît comment ça fonctionne aux
intercommunalités parce que vous avez
créé dans un département comme le mien
vous va structures différentes qui vont
avoir des compétences qui vont pas
la gestion des prestations sociales et à
mon avis il va pas être très chaud pour
prendre le RSA parce qu'aujourd'hui ça
lui va parce qu'il dit on va augmenter
10 %, c'est pas grave c'est lui qui
c'est pas lui qui paye demain ça c'est
lui qui payera mais en ce qui concerne
les autres activités par exemple les
personnes âgées l'enfance la petite
enfance les personnes en difficulté etc
on va pas faire ça 20 petits territoires
à l'intérieur d'un territoire il faut
bien que quelque chose de commun qui est
une politique commune à l'intérieur d'un
territoire et on va pas mettre les gens
dans des conditions différentes dans les
maisons de retraite d'un territoire à un
autre d'une communauté de communes à
notre donc la Fédération c'était le
département
enfin toute façon les choses vont
évoluer moi je vous je peux vous varier
en France en 2017 après les prochaines
présidentielles et les jours
les départements vont renaître de leur
cendre dans lesquels on vient en train
de les mettre actuellement et vont être
certainement plus intéressant à gérer
parce qu'ils ont peut-être des
territoires différents il fusionneront
peut-être avec des départements voisins
avec des compétences communes moi je
suis en train d'essayer fusionner avec
deux départements voisins pour faire un
grand département mais toutes nos
compétences ensemble on fait des
économies et on arrive à avoir des bons
résultats mais ça le gouvernement pour
l'instant le refuge mais ça va changer
on voit sur les images la Bernard
Cazeneuve le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
s'installe devant la commission des Lois
du Sénat donc l'audition va démarrer on
voit que Jean-Pierre Bel président du
Sénat assiste à cette audition
évidemment importante cette réforme
territoriale pour pour le Sénat et pour
les élections sénatoriales de septembre
on en a pas encore parlé mais après la
débâcle des municipales Philippe
cattanbach vous avez peur que ça joue un
peu contre le Parti socialiste il est
certain que les élections municipales
ont un impact fort sur les élections
sanatoriales à suivre
à Nicolas Sarkozy c'est né en 2011 une
élection il y a de très très nombreuses
raisons qui expliquent un résultat il y
a des élections dans chaque département
ivoire une campagne électorale moi je me
garde bien d'annoncer les résultats
avant je crois qu'il y aura vraiment des
résultats qui seront serrés et ceux qui
vendent là pour la peau de l'ours avant
de l'avoir tué à mon avis se trompe
les élections
déjà pour savoir qui sera présent du
Sénat je peux vous dire que les
socialistes
sont en campagne
ils sont en campagne sénatoriale pour
gagner les élections sanatoriales il y a
beaucoup de volonté à droite il y a plus
il y a plus de président vraiment à
gauche mais enfin ça on verra après
personne
reste très longtemps dans les mêmes
fonctions donc voilà c'est bien c'est
quelque chose à l'intérieur si bien sûr
bien sûr il y aura des débats ça
concerne les élus les élus sont motivées
mais je crois que la manière dont le
gouvernement a pris le sujet la main
dans le Sénat va travailler va rassurer
aussi les résultats on le voit à travers
le découpage des régions comme on le
voit à travers les compétences qui vont
être dévoluer région comme on le verra
demain lorsqu'on parlera de
l'organisation à mettre en place pour
les terroristes en euros je crois que
tout le monde comprend qu'on ne peut pas
continuer avec le millefeuille qu'on
peut pas continuer à rajouter des
couches au mille-feuilles qu'on peut pas
continuer à créer des intercommunalités
des métropoles sans se poser la question
de l'organisation d'ensemble le
gouvernement a le courage de le faire le
courage de mener la réforme à terme
parce que la droite on a beaucoup parlé
mais pendant 10 ans on
aboutirailleurs
qui a pas été mis en place de
avec des élections donc là la réforme
elle sera votée elle sera mise en place
il y aura des élections régionales dans
les grandes régions il y aura les
compétences nouvelles pour les régions
je crois que les choses vont commencer à
prendre corps concrètement et vont
continuer à évoluer parce que voilà
l'architecture territoriale
d'évolution avec le groupe socialiste
ici au sénatrice qui sont un petit peu
plus favorables que l'uf c'est très
forme territoriale moi je constate sur
le terrain favorable aux grandes régions
monsieur denigier
le premier texte de loi ne concerne que
le découpage des régions et la date des
élections qui se cache simplement je
constate sur le terrain parce que je lis
tout ce qui se passe je viens des
réunions je constate que sur le terrain
partout où il y a une vraie virulence
contre le texte concernant les
départements et les régions c'est dans
des territoires qui sont à gauche et il
y a vraiment des manifestations très
fortes à gauche il y en a pas eu à
droite pratiquement à gauche elle est
vraie manifestations contre cette
réforme et il y a pas longtemps à Nevers
il y a tous les présidents de conseil
généraux
des conseils départementaux généraux on
sait jamais comment ça s'appelle qui se
sont oui départementaux mais généraux
dans le texte tel qu'il a été voté déjà
d'ailleurs qui se sont réunis à Nevers
les ruraux et qui était fou furieux et
monsieur valini a été très mal reçu par
la gauche et ils sont pas du tout
d'accord avec avec le texte moi j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais d'accord pour
moins de régions moins de départements
et beaucoup plus d'équilibre et pas la
compétence générale donc globalement il
y a des choses qui peuvent nous aller
dans le texte
les Français les citoyens français Eric
de Liger ont envie de cette
simplification territoriale non les
citoyens planification
millefeuille on enlève une feuille ça va
vous coûter beaucoup moins cher
qu'est-ce que vous êtes d'accord ils
disent oui c'est normal enfin tout le
monde dit oui moi aussi je dis oui mais
le problème est de savoir si ça peut
fonctionner comme ça et si c'est la
meilleure méthode alors la réforme oui
une réforme relativement rapide oui
poser la question oui l'avantage au
moins c'est que ça permet le débat et
que ça permet d'avancer après il faut
pas faire n'importe quoi et il faut
vraiment être en capacité de démontrer
qu'on est capable de réduire les coûts
ça c'est important quand même de rien
c'est ce que demande le citoyen aussi la
transparence la clarification les coûts
etc mais les coûts c'est un élément
essentiel or aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu
la démonstration sur les coups et sur le
reste on est encore dans le flou tant
que la loi ne sera pas votée et puis
quand même le président de la Cour des
comptes le premier président a dit
beaucoup de choses intéressantes sur
comment réduire les coûts à l'intérieur
de l'État et des collectivités sur
augmenter les horaires de travail
diminuer le nombre de fonctionnaires moi
tout ça c'est intéressant mais il faut
pas le cas il faut pas se cacher non
plus c'est que derrière toutes ces lois
il y a ces problématiques
justement pour la réforme de l'État qui
doit aller de pair avec la réforme
territoriale les deux doivent avancer de
manière concomitive très bien ben
écoutez merci à tous les deux ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on rejoigne la
salle Clémenceau du Sénat où les débats
autour des présidents de région pour
l'instant se poursuivent le ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard Cazeneuve et dans la
salle il écoute la fin des des
intervenants là c'est Alain Bertrand qui
est en train de s'exprimer vous le voyez
sur cette image on va écouter ce qu'il
dit et puis on dans la suite de ces
interventions et bien entendra le
discours de Bernard Cazeneuve devant les
sénateurs quel message il vient leur
adresse et puis surtout on écoutera
attentivement les questions posées par
la commission des Lois du Sénat au
ministre de l'Intérieur merci à tous les
deux d'être venu sur notre plateau et
donc on suit cette audition de la
commission des lois sur la réforme
territoriale
Cazeneuve Monsieur le Premier Ministre
pour dire qu'on était pas d'accord sur
découpage de la même façon je trouve pas
que tirer argument
du Pays Basque espagnol qui est une
région autonome pour le coup le comparer
avec nos régions françaises soit une
bonne façon de faire entre nous ensuite
ce que je voulais dire au président du
Sénat ont rapporteur et au ministre
c'est que quand on prend cette carte
avec un crayon gris dans famille que la
divise en deux on peut y lire au sud
mathématiquement 4 régions virgule 5 et
au nord 8,5 régions alors d'accord c'est
les compétences on est tous d'accord
d'accord ce qui compte c'est d'avoir la
taille un critique la bonne taille
critique pour une région pour faire de
l'économie de l'emploi et être efficace
dans le cadre de la politique du
président de la République François
Hollande et du gouvernement mais on peut
pas s'en tenir à des côtes mal taillées
la carte il faut la parfaire absolument
et je crée que le sud une fois de plus
nous soyons malheureusement encore trop
loin de Paris d'ailleurs nous en sommes
de plus en plus loin un dernier mot pour
dire que la Lozère pour ne pas évoquer
mon cas avec un conseiller régional sous
la présidence de Jean-Pierre Bell et la
présidence région pierre sueur on a fait
une proposition de loi rdce pour dire
que le minimum minimum monsieur le
ministre pour un département afin qu'il
se représentait à la région c'était
trois conseillers régionaux ce qui
permettait d'en avoir dans la majorité
et de l'opposition si je regarde le cas
du département qui m'intéresse il va y
avoir 150 conseillers régionaux dans la
région
Midi-Pyrénées Languedoc-Roussillon et il
y aura un conseiller régional pour la
Lozère c'est complètement inextractable
au titre des principes républicains et
des principes de de réalité ensuite je
crois que les présidents de région on
dit qu'il souhaitait quelques
modifications de cartographie certains
vous lancer réunir davantage d'autres
préférences d'autres alliances et bien
je crois qu'il nous appartient de faire
une carte qui soit pas une carte pour
dessiner vite mais une carte pour
dessiner bien voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire Monsieur le Président et
Monsieur le Ministre merci Alain
Bertrand enfin on va finir avec la
sagesse de Monsieur
François fortaffin
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs je serai très brève
premièrement je ferai une comparaison
avec la réforme de fer Mitterrand elle
était comprise par l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens parce qu'elle était simple
il s'agissait de rapprocher le citoyen
utilisateur de l'élu décideur
dans cette réforme je cherche vainement
une ligne directrice
ça c'est le premier élément le deuxième
point si on doit réformer pour le
plaisir de réformer
c'est un peu court il fallait d'abord
savoir qu'est-ce qui marche mal
dans notre pays
soit que ce soit fait par le conseil
général que soit fait par le Conseil
régional ou que ce soit fait par les
communes ou les intercommunalités et
ensuite on établit une réforme là j'ai
le sentiment qu'on est dans une certaine
précipitation cela dit moi je fais
confiance à l'intelligence des hommes
pour s'adapter et je ferai une
comparaison
il y a quelques 40 ans tout ce qu'il y
avait en France de démographe de
géographie de politologues de
spécialistes tout bord et de tout poil
il nous disait les campagnes françaises
c'est fini vous pourrez éventuellement
freiner un déclin
inexorable mais vous allez vers une mort
lente c'est tout le contraire qui s'est
produit
alors j'ai le sentiment que peut-être on
trouvera quelques parades tant qu'il y
aura dans ce pays des élus mais
n'oublions pas quand même que notre pays
s'est forgé si s'il est si beau grâce à
un très grand nombre d'élus
même dans les petites communes encore
faudrait-il qu'ils puissent avoir le
sentiment de servir à quelque chose
désormais
qui François forta avec la grande
indulgence de monsieur le ministre
Bernard Cazeneuve je vais demander à nos
présidents de région et d'abord au
président Alain Rousset s'ils peuvent de
manière peut-être un peu
cursive apportée quelques réflexions
oui les interventions si vous le
permettez je m'exprimer au nom des des
collègues à moins que
deux ou trois points
encore une fois nous insistons auprès de
vous pas sur cette
page sur ce projet de loi
sur le fait que ce qui est fondamental
c'est la puissance
que nous sommes réservés pour ne pas
dire plus ça reste entre nous sur les
problèmes de taille
parce que sinon on veut s'occuper des
entreprises des transferts
technologiques et de l'accompagnement
des chômeurs ça suppose une forme de
proximité et que il ne faut surtout pas
que nous ayons une désincarnation après
le résultat des européennes une
désincarnation des politiques menées des
élus menées à l'égard de nos concitoyens
il y a une vraie crainte et je pense
d'ailleurs que le ministre de
l'Intérieur le gouvernement le président
de la République
ont bien pris ça en compte lorsque on
est passé en quelque sorte de 11 à 14
d'une certaine manière
il appartient au législateur que vous
êtes que nous sommes
de faire le cas échéant bouger la carte
j'ai pour ma part moi un regret
personnel mais c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement compliqué sur le plan
constitutionnel démocratique de vitesse
de qu'on n'ait pas pu avoir une un
découpage plus fin
il y a en fait quatre ou cinq
départements qui posent problème
je regarde ma collègue de Charente et de
Charente-Maritime
voilà sur l'aménagement du territoire je
voudrais rassurer les sénateurs qui et
les sénatrices qui sont ici les régions
prendront parfaitement en compte les
territoires ruraux suburbains
pour lesquels une politique
contractuelle doit être mise en place à
l'échelle des pays il ne s'agit pas pour
nous de laisser tomber quelques
territoires que ce soit
les régions les régions prendront la
responsabilité je rappelle quand même
que ce qui est important pour un
territoire c'est que l'activité agricole
l'activité industrielle l'activité
artisanale se développe
plus que les ronds-points
ne
comment dire ne fleurissent si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi
sur
je juste une remarque à deux ou trois
reprises sur mes comparaisons que fait
la RF à l'égard des autres pays
je
comment dire
ne réinventons pas la roue mes chers
collègues il y a des expériences
européennes soyons modestes aussi il y a
des expériences européennes qui
fonctionnent bien en réussite scolaire
mieux que nous et de loin voir les
rapports pizza en santé en santé sauf
que si les régions les départements et
les communes n'avaient pas été là pour
faire bouger l'éducation nationale pour
apprendre les langues pour accompagner
les élèves dans la mobilité pour régler
le problème du logement des jeunes rien
ne se serait passé rien ne se serait
passé
là-dessus pardon d'être un peu passionné
mais quand l'État nous a laissé dans les
années 80 les lycées c'était dans un
état déplorable aujourd'hui
dans toutes les dans tous les lycées
professionnels de France dans tous les
lycées professionnels de France quel que
soit la sensibilité des exécutifs les
élèves travaillent avec le meilleur
matériel et la numérisation des lycées
professionnels les meilleurs
donc là-dessus je crois que il y a eu un
apport et chaque fois qu'il y a eu une
compétence spécialisée cette compétence
a été parfaitement exercée chaque fois
que nous avons des compétences
dispersées
le temps de la décision publique et le
coût de la décision publique et 8 fois
plus élevé et y compris par rapport à
l'État et en saluant le ministre de
l'Intérieur je lui dis
précisément la demande des régions de
France qui est qu'on règle le enfin qui
est plutôt que le problème essentiel
pour nous régions
c'est que l'État
se départissent
nous transfère tous ces doublons
notamment dans le domaine économique
notamment dans le domaine de
l'innovation avec
les régions or il n'y a rien dans la
deuxième loi monsieur le ministre il n'y
a rien le deuxième point qui est
gravissime je l'évoque devant le
ministre et que je vous évoquais tout à
l'heure en gros en innovation les
régions de France
mettent 400 millions d'euros les Landers
allemands
mettent 9 milliards d'euros il ne faut
pas s'étonner si nous n'arrivons pas à
redresser l'industrie française
si demain
sur le plan de la partie des compétences
départementales qui seraient transférées
à la région à travers le développement
économique
et excusez-moi de parler du deuxième
texte qui nous semble plus important que
le premier
si les deux milliards commettent les
départements ne sont pas transférés aux
régions c'est un drame pour les PME et
l'emploi
c'est un drame pour les PME et l'emploi
voilà
je reviens je reviens d'un mot à mes à
mes comparaisons essayons mes chers
collègues et je reprendrai les mots de
notre collègue van Dering donc à partir
avec lequel on a beaucoup travaillé et
je le remercie et les régions de France
remercie les sénateurs et les sénatrices
du travail qui a été fait à diverses
reprises
parce que c'est une petite révolution
culturelle à un moment donné de se dire
le bon niveau du développement
économique le bon niveau du
décloisonnement de la recherche la
formation et l'entreprise c'est la
région
on pouvait se poser la question nous
vous président de Région comment le
Sénat allait réagir un renforcement des
régions donc
félicitations
et remerciements mes chers collègues
mais regardons l'avenir
essayons d'unir les forces politiques et
faisons en sorte et faisons en sorte
aussi que les meilleures expériences
européennes puisse être développés ici
en France on n'est pas attaché forcément
à du conservatisme
merci Alain Rousset je pense que les
différents présidents de région se
reconnaissent dans ce qui a été dit
Laurent Beauvais veut ajouter un mot oui
simplement sur le premier texte la
référence au seuil minimal d'un
conseiller régional par département et
la problématique de la ruralité et
deuxième remarque que j'avais fait tout
à l'heure sur le chef-lieu entre
guillemets ce terme je le trouve un peu
désuet et la préoccupation d'aménagement
du territoire en rapport avec les
métropoles et leurs compétences voilà
bien merci est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres précisions bon écoutez et il me
reste vous savez mes chers collègues
Jean-Pierre belle que je remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous et qui va
prendre la parole immédiatement
me faisait remarquer que 66 sénateurs
étaient venus à cette réunion
il est rare qu'il y ait une hôtel
audience pour une audition c'est un peu
redondant au Sénat
c'est dire Madame et Messieurs les
présidents de région combien nous avons
été très intéressé par ce que vous avez
dit et combien nous souhaitons continuer
à travailler très étroitement avec vous
donc un grand merci et tout de suite
Jean-Pierre Bel va prendre la parole
pour vous avant monsieur le ministre
rapidement merci Jean-Pierre Sueur pour
accueillir monsieur le ministre dans
cette salle Clémenceau lui dire que
c'est une composition un peu
particulière
assez inhabituel ce qui s'est passé cet
après-midi puisque nous avons souhaité
avoir même que nous travaillons sur le
texte en commission et immédiatement
après que les textes aient été présentés
en conseil des ministres et nous sommes
bien sûr le premier texte et pas sur le
second dans le travail que nous opérons
cet après-midi nous avons souhaité
pouvoir avoir cette rencontre dans un
premier temps avec deux séquences la
première avec les présidents de région
qui nous ont apporté un certain nombre
de d'observations et d'enseignements et
puis bien sûr monsieur le ministre la
seconde avec vous-même nous avions
organisé ici je le disais en présentant
en présentant l'après-midi tout à
l'heure nous avions organisé les états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
il est bien évident qu'il ne s'agit pas
de cela cet après-midi mais c'est un peu
l'esprit des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale organisée par le
Sénat il y a déjà quelques mois que nous
avons voulu reprendre en faisant que
ceux qui sont concernés sur ce texte
plus particulièrement mais il y a pas
simplement cet article là puisse le
faire devant les sénateurs et puis bien
sûr vous recevoir vous recevoir nos
collègues en particulier madame la
ministre en arrière Escoffier que je
retrouve avec plaisir ici pour aborder
donc ce premier texte monsieur le
ministre avec la permission du président
de la commission des lois qui va
continuer à présider cette séance je
vous passe la parole
bien Messieurs les Présidents merci
infiniment pour votre accueil à vous
monsieur le Président du Sénat à vous
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois merci à l'ensemble des
sénatrices sénateurs pour
leur présence à l'occasion de
l'ouverture de ces discussions qui vont
s'échelonner au cours des semaines et
des mois qui viennent sur la loi
relative à la délimitation des régions
et aux élections départementales et
régionales j'ai plaisir à être avec vous
quelques heures après que le texte a été
présenté en Conseil des ministres parce
que je sais l'importance que revêt pour
votre assemblée
l'organisation territoriale de la
République vous avez une légitimité
institutionnelle constitutionnelle
particulière qui vous conduit à
connaître toujours avec passion des
sujets qui concernent l'organisation de
nos territoires et entamer après la
présentation du texte au Conseil des
ministres Pays-Bas avec vous et bien
entendu pour moi un grand plaisir je
veux me le permettrez Messieurs les
Présidents salut et tout
particulièrement madame la salatrice
Anne-Marie Escoffier qui a eu à
travailler sur ces sujets jusqu'à une
période récente et qu'il a toujours fait
avec un esprit de grands professionnels
mais en même temps d'ouverture d'esprit
que je partage avec elle et je veux lui
dire de très grand plaisir que j'ai la à
la retrouver ici et salué également
l'ensemble des sénateurs qui exercent
des responsabilités locales comme
président
de collectivités locales importantes je
vois des présidents de région bien
entendu mais aussi des présidents
d'agglomération et de
départements qui connaissent tous
parfaitement la question de
l'organisation territoriale de la
République émettent systématiquement
toujours une grande passion au débat qui
concerne ces sujets
je voudrais tout d'abord dire quelques
mots sur la procédure vous savez que le
gouvernement a fait le choix de la
procédure accélérée et comme je ne
souhaite pas qu'il y ait d'ambiguïté sur
la procédure et la méthode qui a été
choisie par le gouvernement je voudrais
sans tarder vous dire les raisons pour
lesquelles nous avons choisi cette
procédure et puis vous garantir qu'elle
ne sera pas du tout de nature à obérée
la qualité du débat nous avons choisi
cette procédure parce que il y a un très
grand nombre de textes et de réformes
qui vont être engagés que nous ne
pouvons pas contenir de l'urgence
prendre le temps de laisser ses réformes
sans Lisée et qu'il faut absolument
créer les conditions d'un rythme qui
garantissent la réussite de la réforme
en même temps l'urgence ne peut pas
signifier que le débat sera escamoté
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y aura
bien deux lectures de ces textes et que
ces deux lectures précédents la
commission mixte paritaire parce que
c'est la garantie pour le comme pour
l'Assemblée nationale que les
parlementaires qui ont encore une fois
une passion de ces sujets une volonté de
faire prévaloir leur point de vue
pourront le faire totalement et je veux
en même temps que je vous donne ces
garanties vous dire ma totale
disponibilité totale et entière
disponibilités pour aller au fond des
choses pendant les débats mais aussi
mais aussi je le dis pour rencontrer
celles et ceux des parlementaires
appartenant à des groupes d'études ou à
des groupes politiques qui souhaiteront
venir faire prévaloir des points de vue
sur les sujets qui seront sur le métier
à l'occasion de ce débat
je voudrais également avant d'entrer
dans le vif du sujet dire quelques mots
sur
l'ensemble des sujets que nous avons sur
le métier pour montrer qu'il y a
derrière la démarche du gouvernement une
préoccupation première qui est une
préoccupation de cohérence
nous avons le souhait de réformer
l'administration territoriale de l'État
et des collectivités territoriales pour
donner plus de force à notre pays au
moment il doit
surmonter les difficultés auxquelles il
est confronté notamment en matière
économique notre objectif est de donner
plus de force à nos territoires de leur
donner davantage de chances de pouvoir
compter dans une compétition qui est de
plus en plus rude non seulement entre
les territoires à l'intérieur de
l'Hexagone mais au plan européen et la
volonté qui est la nôtre est assez
simple et s'articule à des objectifs qui
sont eux aussi aisés à énoncer
premièrement nous voulons des
intercommunalités qui soient plus forte
permettre dans un pays qui compte 36 000
communes à des intercommunalités de
s'organiser davantage de monter en gamme
de monter en puissance pour pouvoir
prendre la maîtrise d'ouvrage de
politique publique dont les territoires
ont besoin notamment les territoires
ruraux qui ont une crainte considérable
de relégation est utile pour le
territoire deuxièmement nous avons
besoin parce qu'il y a un enchevêtrement
de compétences qui n'améliorent pas la
lisibilité pour le citoyen du
fonctionnement de nos collectivités
locales une nécessité de clarification
des compétences il n'y a pas de
démocratie locale là où il n'y a pas de
lisibilité dans l'organisation des
collectivités locales et vouloir faire
en sorte à travers la loi que
présenteront Marylise de branchu André
Vallini qu'il y est une clarification
des compétences pour améliorer la
lisibilité du fonctionnement de nos
institutions locales est une manière
aussi de garantir une meilleure
compréhension par les citoyens de
l'organisation
territorial de la République
troisième point nous avons besoin
de régions plus fortes dans une Europe
j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure où les
régions ont une taille critique qui est
bien au-delà de ce qu'est la taille de
nos propres régions est-ce que disait
Alain Rousset tout à l'heure sur la
capacité des Lander allemand investis de
façon massive dans leur filière
d'excellence et dans les infrastructures
qui feront la compétitivité de demain
n'est pas sans lien quoi qu’on en dise
avec la taille de ces régions et
d'ailleurs pour mettre plongée j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure dans les
préoccupations qui furent ceux celles de
ceux qui ont créé les établissements
publics régionaux il y a de ça plus de
50 ans la préoccupation de la taille
était déjà présente comme un élément de
l'efficacité de l'action publique et
enfin il faut c'est important organiser
l'administration déconcentré de l'état
de manière à ce que celle-ci soit plus
efficace qu'après de nombreuses années
où les logiques de rabots ont constitué
une situation une question d'appory sur
les territoires nous puissions avoir une
administration déconcentrée de l'État
forte et puissante qui puissent être un
interlocuteur reconnu de la part des
collectivités locales qui ont besoin
d'avoir en face d'elle des compétences
d'ingénierie et des services publics qui
assurent aux citoyens
asservissent de qualité et nous avons
besoin là aussi d'engager cette réforme
de l'administration des concentrés de
l'État avec davantage de préoccupations
d'interministérialité pour que les
préfets et les moyens d'organiser les
services locaux de façon plus efficiente
il faut faire une revue des missions de
service public pour éviter les doublons
dont parler d'un certain nombre d'élus
tout à l'heure notamment les présidents
de région il faut une charte de
déconcentration qui après que les
missions ont été clarifiées permettra à
l'état d'être plus efficace sur les
territoires il nous faut également créer
les conditions c'était votre
préoccupation monsieur le sénateur d'un
État qui puisse localement avec
davantage de souplesse organiser ses
services mettre en place la fongibilité
de ces budgets sans que cela ne remette
en cause à aucun moment les garanties
auxquelles nous tenons et qui sont
celles données à nos fonctionnaires qui
remplissent des missions sur nos
territoires c'est parce que les enjeux
sont ceux-ci qu'ils sont globaux qui
sont à l'origine d'une cohérence que
nous souhaitons que nous sommes
convaincus au gouvernement le président
de la République l'a dit le 14 janvier
le Premier ministre la réaffirmé le 8
avril à l'occasion de son discours de
politique générale que nous sommes
convaincus que c'est dans la mise en
œuvre de cette cohérence que nous
parviendrons à redresser nos territoires
que ces textes sont présentés devant
vous et c'est aussi parce qu'il y a
urgence
alors je voudrais quand même à tous ceux
qui légitimement s'interrogent les ai
entendus à l'occasion de nos contacts
préalables à cette réunion car il y a
dans cette salle beaucoup d'amis avec
lesquels j'ai une relation de confiance
et assez spontanée pour qu'il me dise
des choses sans précaution donc je
connais la pensée de certains d'entre
vous sans connaître la pensée de chacun
car contenu de mes fonctions cela
pourrait sembler suspect mais quand même
nous avons eu l'occasion les uns et les
autres de nous parler de temps à autre
donc je sais qu'il y a parmi vous un
certain nombre de sénateurs élus de
collectivités locales qui considère que
il est urgent d'attendre encore de
prendre le temps de la réflexion
et je peux le comprendre je veux
simplement rappeler que le 5 mars 2009
lorsque Édouard Balladur a remis son
rapport au président de la République de
l'époque après que le Président de la
République de l'époque lui avait demandé
d'engager une réflexion sur les
évolutions institutionnelles dont notre
pays avait besoin son rapport
s'intitulait il est temps de décider
c'était il y a 5 ans
et 5 ans après même si il faut avoir
l'honnêteté en toute chose de
reconnaître et notamment sur ces
matières que des choses ont été engagées
la réorganisation de nos collectivités
locales avec l'ambition qui doit
s'attacher précisément aux urgences n'a
pas encore été mise sur le métier n'a
pas encore eu lieu et lorsque
Jean-Pierre Raffarin et le sénateur
gratiné ont engagé une réflexion dans le
cadre de la mission sur l'avenir de
l'organisation territoriale de la
République ils ont eux aussi proposé des
évolutions proposer une réduction du
nombre de régions bien plus ambitieuses
finalement que celle que nous proposons
aujourd'hui puisqu'il proposait de créer
10 régions mais nous sommes dans une
situation où ces préconisations n'ont
pas encore été mises en œuvre donc ce
que nous souhaitons c'est ne pas
attendre davantage c'est prendre le
risque d'essayer c'est de faire des
propositions qui ne sont pas un seul de
tout compte parce que dans cette
assemblée
les propositions ne sont jamais à soldes
de tout compte même si on a l'impudence
ou l'imprudence de le considérer à la
fin on sait que le débat aura lieu que
des propositions seront faites que des
avis seront émis dont il faudra
grandement tenir compte pour faire en
sorte que le texte au moment où il
sortira du Sénat puisse être meilleur
que lorsqu'il y est rentré et cela est
toujours possible et il y a trop
d'expérience ici trop
de connaissances trop d'expérience pour
ne pas considérer que ce but est
susceptible d'être atteint au Sénat sur
ce texte dès lors que la volonté est de
faire un bon texte dans l'intérêt du
pays mais si nous ne prenons pas le
risque de prendre notre risque
c'est à dire de poser une carte
de présenter un tableau pour que le
débat s'engage et que la réforme est une
chance alors une fois de plus il ne se
passera rien
et le gouvernement a donc pris le risque
de prendre son risque pour donner une
chance à la réforme il le fait avec la
volonté de l'écoute il le fait avec la
volonté d'être le plus près de vous pour
faire en sorte que cette loi parce que
c'est l'intérêt du débat parlementaire
monte en gamme et avec la volonté
d'aboutir
enfin je voudrais insister et ces
derniers points ensuite je présenterai
brièvement les grands éléments de la loi
pour que nous puissions avoir le temps
du débat je voudrais insister sur le
fait que
avoir de grandes régions
lorsque depuis des années des présidents
de région de façon excellente il y a ici
François Patriat il y avait d'autres
présidents de région tout à l'heure on
fait un travail considérable pour que
l'économie soit davantage accompagnée et
quand je parle de l'économie je parle
des filières d'excellence je passe dans
l'organisation de la relation entre les
centres de recherche université les
centres de transfert de technologie nos
filières industrielles d'excellence je
pense aux investissements dans lesquels
les régions se sont engagées de façon
massive avec des résultats significatifs
sur l'emploi dans le domaine de
l'investissement numérique dans le
domaine des transports de demain dans le
domaine des énergies de demain et des
énergies renouvelables ces
investissements là ont permis à notre
pays d'avoir de la croissance de porter
haut les couleurs d'un certain nombre de
nos filières remarquables au plan
européen et l'idée c'est de faire en
sorte à travers ces regroupements de
régions que nous puissions faire en
sorte qu'il y ait de la mutualisation
entre certains nombres de
le service qui relève du fonctionnement
ou du back office des régions pour
dégager des marges de manoeuvre afin
d'investir davantage cela est possible
et deuxièmement c'est de faire en sorte
que nous puissions atteindre la taille
critique qui permette au moment où la
révolution numérique a fait son œuvre ou
les transports de demain et la grande
vitesse à introduit une autre forme de
relation entre les territoires de faire
en sorte que nous puissions être
davantage armés pour faire face à cette
urgence je dois d'ailleurs
vous dire pour avoir un peu regardé
l'histoire de notre
de notre République au cours des
dernières décennies que cette
préoccupation a été systématiquement
celle de ceux qui ont pris le risque de
la réforme je voudrais juste vous lire
une déclaration du général de Gaulle qui
lorsqu'il a créé les établissements
publics régionaux avaient la
préoccupation de la taille et de la de
la juste périmètre et voilà ce que le
général de Gaulle écrit dans les
mémoires d'espoir les collectivités à la
naissance de la 5ème république tout
juste tel qu'elle furent créées à la
mort de l'ancien régime c'est-à-dire
bien trop petite pour la vie moderne où
l'économie domine tout avec ses
exigences d'aménagement et d'équipements
étendus et planifiés général de Gaulle
alors dans les mémoires énumère les
changements techniques qui se sont
produits l'évoque l'arrivée du
télégraphe de l'automobile qui ont
dit-il conduit à rapetisser les
départements et en conclu je cite le
général de Gaulle qu'il faut élargir les
circonscriptions françaises à la mesure
de ce que requiert désormais la vie
pratique et le développement
donc les réflexions qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui lorsque nous présentons
cette modernisation et le gaulisme que
vous êtes devrait pas être peiné de ce
que je viens de lire
voilà
un texte et la date est totalement un
hasard à chacun selon sa taille en toute
matière il y a là des pistes des
réflexions qui montrent finalement que
nous sommes dans une permanence de
préoccupation alors comment
dont les actes que nous posons quel est
le contenu du texte de loi pour faire en
sorte qu'entre l'ambition de la
modernité de l'efficacité de
l'investissement de la modernisation
économique nous puissions atteindre le
but comment le faire d'abord il y a
effectivement l'article 1 qui finalement
propose une carte régionale il s'agit à
partir de 15 régions existant de n'en
faire que 6 en procédant à des
regroupements sur lesquels je ne reviens
pas que je ne crierai pas parce que vous
les connaissez fort bien les avez déjà
abondamment commenté d'autres régions au
nombre
de
8 resteront tels qu'en elle-même parce
qu'elles ont déjà une taille critique
cette évolution à laquelle nous
procédons qui nous conduit à privilégier
la taille plutôt que le nombre les
enjeux économiques custaux que tout
notre considération nous met dans la
moyenne des régions européennes des pays
les plus performants je veux la donner
quelques chiffres et je n'en donnerai
pas trop les Länders Allemands ont une
taille moyenne de 5,3 enfin nombre
d'habitants de 5,3 millions d'habitants
nous serons à 4,3 millions là où il y a
deux il y a actuellement avec 22 régions
2,6 millions d'habitants en moyenne
l'Italie est à 4,1 millions d'habitants
là où la moyenne
si l'on intègre les régions à statut
exceptionnelle est à peine au-dessous de
cadre donc nous sommes vraiment dans la
moyenne européenne je veux donner un
autre chiffre qui montre que en
procédant à se regroupements nous créons
les conditions d'une nombreux disparité
entre les régions de France quand on
prend aujourd'hui la plus petite région
de France à l'exception de
l'Île-de-France est la plus grande on
est dans un rapport de 1 à 9 lorsque
nous aurons procédé à ce regroupement
nous serons dans un rapport de 1 à 3
c'est à dire qu'il y aura davantage
d'équilibre territorial qu'il y en a
aujourd'hui parce que nous aurons
rapproché les régions en leur donnant la
possibilité d'être davantage équilibré
les unes par rapport aux autres
enfin
je voudrais
par de la se regroupement
est contenu des questions qu'il peut
poser quel que soit la carte que nous
aurions présenté leur effet débat
c'est la raison pour laquelle il fallait
bien en présenter une et penser qu'il
puisse y avoir une carte dans cette
salle qui fasse l'unanimité compte tenu
de l'histoire de chacun de l'histoire de
chaque région du fait aussi qu'il puisse
y avoir derrière des cartes des
espérances ça n'est jamais exclu en
politique et ça n'est pas forcément
inhumain et désagréable que de le vivre
et par conséquent désagréable que de le
dire ça peut exister
il n'y aurait il n'y avait pas de de
cartes dont nous étions garantis qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat elle
susciterait spontanément immédiatement
amicalement l'adhésion il faut toujours
encore une fois prendre le risque de
présenter une carte et de la soumettre
au débat d'autant plus que le pouvoir
d'amendement est là pour faire en sorte
que la carte soit plus pertinente si
vous avez des solutions qui permettent
d'atteindre le but mais
derrière la carte je comprends que les
questions peuvent se poser il y a des
éléments d'histoire il y a des éléments
d'identité il y a des attachements il y
a des coopérations qui se sont nouées et
décider de modifier ses frontières peut
bien entendu légitimement poser des
interrogations peut susciter des
craintes et ses interrogations et ses
craintes ne sont pas elles n'ont plus
illégitimes et il est tout à fait
logique que ces interrogations et ses
craintes s'expriment je pense
à un certain nombre de régions le
président Richard était là tout à
l'heure il m'a fait part de son
sentiment avec le maire
sénateur mère de Strasbourg sur l'Alsace
et l'Alsace à une identité elle est
prête à la dépasser cette identité que
le historien Jean-Marie Meyer appelait
la région histoire en parlant de de
l'Alsace bon vous acceptez vous êtes
dans une perspective vous êtes prêt à la
dépasser parce que vous savez qu'il
entre ce que l'histoire ce que sont les
racines d'une région et ce que peut être
cet avenir son avenir et c'est se
dépassement que nous devons construire à
travers ce texte et il est tout à fait
possible dit parvenir en sachant que
pour y parvenir et c'est le souhait du
gouvernement et je le dis dès à présent
au moment où j'évoque le découpage des
interrogations qu'il peut susciter et au
moment où je suis conscient du pouvoir
d'amendement du Sénat le Gouvernement a
souhaité poser des principes et qui sont
des principes qui sont comme autant
d'éléments de débat nous ne souhaitons
pas que la modification de la carte
finissent par aboutir à la fin du débat
à autant voir plus de régions qu'il y en
avait au moment où nous sommes rentrés
au Sénat sinon ça veut dire qu'il n'y a
plus de réformes
si nous devons sortir
de l'exercice de voir d'amendement avec
une carte des régions qui présenteraient
plus de régions à la fin qu'il y en
aurait au début les citoyens sera
légitimes à s'interroger sur les
objectifs et les buts que nous
poursuivions et puis par ailleurs pour
ne pas créer de confusion pour ne pas
créer un débat sans fin le gouvernement
ne souhaite pas non plus que l'on puisse
détacher des régions
des départements des régions existantes
pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait à la fin
une carte qui garde cette force et sa
cohésion voilà pour l'article 1
l'article 2 crée
un périmètre sur la question un
périmètre de réflexion et un périmètre
de droit sur la question du chef-lieu
nous savons très bien que le chef-lieu
du domaine réglementaire notre objectif
est de faire en sorte aussi que les
territoires puissent sur cette question
là se saisir de la question de la
capitale et la traiter démocratiquement
entre eux c'est la raison pour laquelle
trois mois après la publication du texte
la possibilité sera donnée d'engager le
débat dans les territoires si le débat
aboutit à la désignation d'une capitale
le gouvernement l'a constatera par
décret si la capitale n'est pas ne va
pas de soi nous la proposerons c'est à
dire que nous proposerons plutôt le
chef-lieu
où se réunira pour la première fois
l'assemblée régionale il appartiendra à
ce moment-là à l'assemblée régionale de
confirmer ou non le choix que nous avons
fait par la voie réglementaire nous
avons décidé de limiter à 150 le nombre
de conseillers régionaux par région ce
qui représente sur un volume global de
côté régionaux une diminution du nombre
de conseillers régionaux de 146-147
c'est-à-dire la peine 9% ce qui est très
peu contenu du nombre d'élus que nous
avons en France mais bien entendu ce
sujet est un sujet qui est là aussi dans
le débat et pour répondre à la
préoccupation d'un certain nombre de
sénateurs qui sont exprimés notamment
monsieur le sénateur de la Lozère tout à
l'heure nous avons souhaité que chaque
section départementale d'une région
puisse avoir des représentants au
conseil régional je sais pour avoir
rencontré un certain nombre d'entre vous
que le nombre de conseillers régionales
représentant ces départements petits de
grandes régions peut susciter des
interrogations et notamment peut
alimenter des craintes de décrochage ou
de relégation ces éléments-là auront
également être abordés dans le cadre du
débat parlementaire qui est bien là pour
permettre à l'ensemble des sénateurs
comme des députés d'aborder ces
questions je voudrais également vous
indiquer que dans l'article 12 il prévu
de modifier le calendrier
électoral vous savez que la loi de mai
2013 prévoyait une concomitance entre
les élections régionales et les
élections départementales nous ouvrons
de nouvelles perspectives en refondant
la carte des régions nous ouvrons de
nouvelles perspectives en engageant une
clarification des compétences dès lors
que nous souhaitons que les deux
élections aient lieu au même moment et
que ce chantier est ouvert nous
proposons le report des élections
régionales et départementales à la fin
de l'année 2015 de telle sorte parce que
entre le vote et la promulgation de la
loi et les élections il est suffisamment
de temps pour que les citoyens puissent
s'approprier la nouvelle configuration
territoriale résultant de nos débats
parlementaires il est également prévu
dans ce texte la fin du mandat des
conseillers départementaux en 2020 et le
remplacement des conseillers département
manteau élus pas à partir du scrutin
binominal de manière à ce que l'on ne
soit pas obligé de faire des missionner
la totalité du binôme lorsque l'un des
élus est empêché qu'il soit possible de
procéder à ces ronds à son remplacement
dans des conditions conformément à la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel du
16 mai 2013 qui soit plus facile à
mettre en oeuvre que ce qui était prévu
initialement enfin il y a disposition
concernant la métropole lyonnaise que
chacun connaît la métropole lyonnaise a
vocation à se substituer au département
du Rhône pour la le périmètre de son
territoire d'intervention les
conseillers généraux départementaux de
la métropole lyonnaise verront de par la
loi leur fonction CC au premier décembre
2015 voilà ce que contient ce texte de
loi voilà les orientations qu'il propose
la philosophie qui l'inspire
sinon on essaie je conclus par cela très
vite si l'on essaie de replacer ce texte
dans la continuité ou dans la
perspective des textes
portant organisation de nos
collectivités territoriales et qui ont
pu voir le jour depuis
le début de la Troisième République la
Troisième République a mis en place la
liberté des communes parce qu'elle
considère notamment qu'en milieu rural
il était important que la démocratie fut
confortée
ce fut une grande réforme qui a pendant
des décennies et jusqu'à nos jours
contribuer à faire vivre une démocratie
locale extraordinairement riche et dense
sur le territoire de notre pays
les élus et acteurs issus de la
Résistance ont considérés qu'il était
important après que la France avait été
détruite de créer les conditions d'un
aménagement du territoire qui donne à
chaque partie du territoire national
sachant la décentralisation portée par
Gaston Defferre et François Mitterrand a
donné par
plus de champs
accordés à l'administration à la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales aux élus les moyens de
peser sur l'avenir de leur territoire et
de s'engager résolument pour que ceux-ci
se développe aujourd'hui il s'agit dans
une crise économique profonde qui ne
répond pas aussi habituel auquel les
crises économiques étaient généralement
soumis une chance
donner une chance à le territoire de
pouvoir surmonter la crise en
investissant et en accompagnant leur
filière d'excellence
bien entendu une réforme dans la crise
et dans la crise économique pour donner
des chances à un pays de sortir de la
crise et toujours une réforme beaucoup
plus discutée qu'une réforme qui se
présente dans un contexte de croissance
lorsqu'il y a beaucoup à partager
et dans un pays qui a la passion du
débat public
les choses sont plus vives encore
qu'elles ne le sont dans d'autres pays
je voudrais conclure mon propos en vous
citant une phrase
de Mirabeau qui
Mirabeau c'était intéressant ce plan
historique parce que
c'est intéressant parce que il s'est
exprimé au moment où on a créé les
départements auxquels beaucoup d'entre
vous sont attachés ici
oui mais c'était nombreux
ce n'est pas le dessin que je nous
souhaite pour aucun d'entre nous et ce
n'est pas peut se finir autrement dans
la grande tradition du Sénat par la
confrontation le compromis et la qualité
d'un texte mais voilà ce qui crie
Mirabeau au moment où on a transformé
les provinces en département il disait
je sais bien qu'on couperait ni des
maisons ni des clochers mais on
trancherait il savait pas ce qu'il
attendait le pauvre ce qui est plus
inséparable on trancherait tous les
liens que resserre depuis si longtemps
les mœurs les habitudes les productions
et le langage c'est à dire que lorsque
l'on crée il y a fort longtemps les
départements à partir des provinces en
découpant les provinces en département
les débats qui se présentent à l'époque
sur la question de l'identité de la
pertinence du sens politique de ce qui
est fait sont exactement les mêmes que
ceux qui vont nous mobiliser au cours
des prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois c'est la raison pour laquelle il y
a une un intérêt de l'histoire qui est
celui de nous permettre de relativiser
les choses et nous aidons relativiser
les choses de nous aider à trouver la
sagesse de les surmonter lorsqu'elle
nous divise pour faire en sorte de
trouver le bon compromis je suis
convaincu que ici au Sénat cela est
possible et vous pouvez compter sur mon
entière disponibilité encore une fois
pour y contribuer
bien merci monsieur le ministre
comme nous sommes en plus enregistré le
télévisé je précise naturellement que
Mirabeau n'a pas été guillotiné il est
mort dans son lit bien à quel âge
monsieur van di renne donc
ah oui bon
bien alors
je conjointement avec Jean-Pierre Bel
président du Sénat je remercie monsieur
le ministre Bernard Cazeneuve qui a fait
preuve une fois encore nous le voyons
tous les jours en ce moment avant-hier
hier aujourd'hui sans doute demain
après-demain de son sens de la pédagogie
et de se calme impressionnant qu'il
déploie en toute occasion qui est une
bonne réponse par rapport à toujours les
tentations qui existent parfois de
perdre le calme je n'ai jamais vu qu'il
le perdit
mes chers collègues nous allons donner
la parole au rapporteur monsieur
Delebarre
monsieur le Président non mais je
voudrais pas toutes les heures
recommencer
le même état mais préoccupations mais je
poursuivrai simplement la réflexion de
monsieur le ministre nous sommes dans
une approche c'est vrai provoquer dans
la mesure où une carte a été affichée
nous avons des principes pour l'examiner
qui ne sont pas des principes de
reconnaissance d'un découpage acharné
pour essayer de transformer en 26
régions les régions qui nous sont
proposées et on doit se garder donc de
partir vers n'importe quelle
considération
j'entends des considérations sur des
rapprochements régionaux qui sont
intéressantes
par ailleurs certains voudraient
peut-être
consolutionnent des problèmes qui n'ont
jamais été réglées qui ne seront pas non
plus d'ailleurs
à l'occasion de se débat je redis que
nous avons une vigilance sur le fait de
laisser les départements au sein des
régions où il se situe à l'heure
actuelle et que peut-être pourrions-nous
arriver à trouver des solutions qui
rassemblent une traînette majorité au
sein de notre assemblée un peu
l'impression que le moteur de ce
rassemblement sera strictement le
voulons nous ou non
si nous ne le voulons pas c'est un texte
à l'occasion duquel on peut trouver
toutes les raisons
j'allais dire de se prendre le bec ou de
trouver des arguments
contradictoires à ceux qui ont été
évoqués par tel ou telle proposition si
nous le voulons le Sénat franchiré je
crois une étape très importante
dans l'édification du contexte de nos
relations entre les collectivités
locales c'est vraiment un choix devant
va se devant lequel va se retrouver le
Sénat sachant que n'oublions pas que
nous allons ainsi dessiner le cadre des
compétences
qui seront abordés dans la foulée et que
si tout le monde est prêt à parler des
compétences beaucoup ont dit il vaut
mieux parler des compétences avant
d'avoir le découpage je crains
simplement que ce soit un peu la volonté
de ne pas s'affronter aux problèmes qui
est peut-être
a priori le plus compliqué mais qui sera
je vois celui qui sera le plus moteur
pour la construction de l'avenir
merci Monsieur Delebarre je vais
demander qui s'inscrit j'ai déjà
l'inscription de Monsieur sido monsieur
Richard
monsieur gros Didier
monsieur buffet
monsieur Néry monsieur Pozzo di Borgo
monsieur Mezard monsieur detrigne
alors Monsieur Favier
monsieur savavier monsieur Favier
monsieur Savary pardonnez-moi
monsieur Mazuir Bertrand Monsieur
Bertrand
bien alors je relis pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'erreur ici Monsieur sido monsieur
Richard monsieur Grosdidier buffet Néry
Pozzo di Borgo mezarde Favier Savary m'a
sur Bertrand est-ce qu'il y a pas
d'autres demandes donc vous voyez qu'il
serait bien quand même que l'on
fasse que l'on va se ramasse autant que
faire ce peu le propos monsieur sido
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre
brillante exposé introductif qui qui
nous donne une parfaite synthèse
naturellement du texte que l'on a lu
depuis la sortie du Conseil des
ministres
nous venons de d'auditionner un certain
nombre de présidents de Conseils
Régionaux actuel
je sais pas comment ils ont été choisis
et voilà Champagne-Ardenne par exemple
il y avait pas la Lorraine non plus je
trouvais que c'était dommage non je vous
demande je demande à pouvoir préciser
les choses nous nous sommes adressés à
l'Association des régions de France et
le président a fait a fait appel au
président non mais nous n'intervenons
pas nous n'intervons pas dans
l'organisation de l'Association des
régions de France allez-y mon cher
collègue parce que je n'ai pas
l'intention de parler boutique et demain
je n'ai pas l'intention de parler de
boutique et de mes petites affaires
d'accord non non mais je parle en tant
que parlementaire sur des sujets de fond
cette audition m'a donné froid dans le
dos
c'était peut-être la climatisation me
direz-vous mais froid dans le dos parce
que ces messieurs n'avaient dans la
bouche qu'un mot puissance
ça m'a choqué
et
je ne voudrais pas être le premier
ministre et le président de la
République après-demain face à ces
nouveaux féodaux
et je me mets à la place des anciens roi
de France
qui ont tout fait pour s'en débarrasser
et c'est Louis XIV finalement a réussi à
le faire
bon je vous souhaite donc bonne chance
mais vous savez que l'appétit vient en
mangeant et que ils n'auront jamais
assez de compétences et que après avoir
avalé tout ce qu'on va leur offrir je
leur ai expliqué que c'était pas si
simple que ça je sais pas s'ils ont bien
compris ils ont été un peu vexés mais
après vous demanderont le droit de
réglementer puis ensuite le droit de
légiférer et puis bref alors je c'est
mon impression de deux heures d'écoute
attentive moi j'aurai deux questions
monsieur le ministre à vous poser et je
comprends bien que au fond pour faire
cette nouvelle carte il vous était
difficile
d'accepter le découpage des régions et
encore plus le découpage des
départements
c'est déjà assez compliqué en prenant
des régions en entier bien je comprends
parfaitement mais on peut comprendre
également que les anciennes régions
n'étant pas forcément très pertinentes
l'association de deux régions pas
forcément très pertinentes me donner un
résultat pas forcément très pertinent
voilà bon je n'arrive droit donc au
droit d'option
la situation actuelle grâce à Monsieur
Charasse
est très compliqué puisqu'il faut un
référendum et le président du conseil
régional d'Alsace c'est plein à merment
il s'en est pas toujours parmi
visiblement de ce qui est arrivé ou
plutôt ce qui n'est pas arrivé en Alsace
je pense qu'il faudra quand même y
réfléchir et je me pose la question si
le gouvernement pourrait pas
éventuellement déposer un amendement ou
le faire déposer c'est ne pas le faire
sur lui-même sur la suppression du
référendum
voilà tout simplement l'obligation d'un
référendum pour permettre à un
département avec l'accord de sa région
de départ et l'accord de la région
d'arrivée de changer de région je pense
que ce serait une bonne chose et que
vous soulèveriez vous réglez bien les
questions bien des réticences au moment
de la discussion de cette loi à mon avis
deuxièmement sur le mode d'élection des
conseillers départementaux à des
conseillers départementaux qui vont être
élus pour pas très longtemps et pour
liquider
les départements et
sous la forme de la loi de 2013
autrement dit de binôme
très pratiquement on va pas redémarrer
sur le binôme à parité c'est fait c'est
la loi mais
très pratiquement pensez-vous qu'on va
trouver beaucoup de candidats
parce qu'il s'agit bien de ça finalement
elle pourrait être
conseillé départementaux une fois
pendant quatre ans
oui mais bon vous voyez ce que je veux
dire et je me pose la question de savoir
Monsieur le Ministre s'il ne serait pas
opportun et de pratiquer ces élections
ces dernières élections départementales
enfin les premières les dernières parce
qu'avant c'était les conseillers avec
l'ancien mode de scrutin à tout le mois
je déposerai un amendement pour pour le
faire mais je pense que ce serait
également une bonne chose parce que le
premier ministre lui-même nous l'a dit
on était quatre ou cinq j'étais pas le
seul nous avons mal travaillé il l'a
reconnu c'était dans son bureau et nous
avons mal travaillé et par conséquent
j'en conclus que on peut redémarrer sur
l'ancien mode de scrutin toute façon ce
sera la dernière fois
si tentait qu'en 2020 la décision soit
prise de supprimer les départements ce
qui n'est pas encore fait merci monsieur
le ministre
merci Monsieur sido la suggestion que
vous avez faite il m'est arrivé de
l'entendre sur divers bancs ont dit
toujours bon bien qu'il n'y ait pas
tellement de banc ce qui prouve que
l'intelligence sénatoriale progresse
toujours
que ceux qui ont des oreilles entendront
alors Monsieur Richard
la première consiste concerne le tableau
du nombre de conseillers régionaux qui
est annexé au projet de loi qui est donc
figurait au code électoral s'il est
adopté
qui
aboutit à la différence du tableau
actuellement en vigueur à une grande
disparité
de représentations des conseillers
régionaux suivant les régions
le tableau actuel
qui a évolué plusieurs reprises enfin
qui est en réalité issue de du système
créé en 86 à la création des régions en
gros fait progresser le nombre de
conseils régionaux avec la population de
la région
de façon moins que proportionnelle c'est
à dire qu'une région qui est deux fois
plus peuplée que que la voisine n'a pas
deux fois plus de conseil régionaux mais
à peu près une fois une libre ça
s'inspire de façon on retrouve
d'ailleurs le même système au Parlement
européen
du fait des fusions proposées de
certaines régions et pas d'autres
on retrouve maintenant des situations
dans lesquelles
la représentation démographique des
conseils régionaux va être très
disparaître c'est une un constat assez
regrettable qu'on avait fait en ce qui
concerne les conseillers en ce qui
concerne les conseils généraux que le
gouvernement est le Parlement n'avait
pas cru de voir Modifier quand on a
instauré le nouveau mode de scrutin
c'est à dire que
il y a des conseillers généraux qui
représentent des populations très
faibles parce qu'ils sont nombreux dans
des départements peuplés et vice versa
donc on va se retrouver dans cette
situation avec en tout cas des ruptures
claires d'égalité avec des régions moins
peuplées qui auront plus de conseils
régionaux que d'autres alors on peut
tout à fait comprendre
qu'il y est une transition organisée
mais je fais observer que dans d'autres
cas on a pu avoir une solution de
transition pendant un mandat
et revenir ensuite à une répartition
plus logique plus cohérente du nombre de
conseillers régionaux donc je pose la
question de savoir si le gouvernement
peut envisager cette cette modalité
la deuxième question porte sur ce qui se
passe en mars 2020 si j'en crois le
texte actuel
puisque on explique donc que le mandat
des conseillers départementaux élus en
décembre 2015 expirera en mars 2020
sauf erreur de ma part le mandat des
conseillers municipaux et communautaires
et lui en mars 2014
et expire également en mars 2020
et on ajoute dans le projet de loi ce
qui est nouveau que le mandat des
conseillé
régionaux élus en décembre 2015 va
également
expirer en mars 2020
et par contre tous les modes de scrutin
restent en vigueur
c'est à dire que les articles du code
électoral qui organisent
l'élection du conseil départemental
reste en vigueur
donc
comme vous le savez article 72 de la
Constitution
l'école l'activité locale s'administre
librement par des conseils élus
donc à défaut de disposition
prévoirait la suppression des
départements en mars 2020
les départements collectivités
territoriales existeront toujours
leur mode de scrutin
sera toujours en vigueur puisque pour
l'instant personne ne propose de la
Breger donc ne vous paraît-il pas
cohérent que le législateur complète
l'opération
faute de pouvoir ni de vouloir puisque
je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de réelles
majorité pour dire on supprime le
département à terme c'est une intention
mais c'est une à mon avis ça reste une
éventualité ne serait-il pas logique de
prévoir la continuité d'une assemblée
élue qui peut l'être au scrutin indirect
pour administrer la collectivité
départementale qui en l'état actuel du
droit continuera à exister en avril 2020
enfin le dernier point
tout simple
est-ce que
l'expertise de nos amis de la
DGCL
toujours prêt à toujours faire répondre
à tout nous assure que le processus
administratif et financier
de fusion de région peut-être achevée si
la loi qui réorganise les régions et les
fusionnent
entre en vigueur le premier janvier 2016
peut-on avoir une description d'abord
être sûr que le dispositif législatif en
place
assure la réponse à toutes les questions
que pose la fusion des régions et attend
une appréciation raisonnable de
l'aboutissement de ce processus avant le
31 décembre 2015
merci Monsieur Richard monsieur
Grosdidier
bien
monsieur le ministre
je trouve que
à la fois votre propos a été très ouvert
notamment sur en faisant appel à la
sagesse du Sénat et sur l'ouverture à
certains amendements mais un peu des
obligeant lorsque vous dites que selon
certains sénateurs il serait
urgent d'attendre je crois que il y a
pas un seul sénateur il est urgent
d'attendre et essayer effectivement
Edouard Balladur déjà qui était temps de
décider vous avez omis
la réforme territoriale qui a créé le
conseiller territorial qui rapprochait
département et régions qui a été
condamné par votre propre opposition à
l'opposition devenue majorité qui a tenu
d'abord à rétablir la clause de
compétences générales et aujourd'hui
vous nous parlez de nécessité de
spécialisation que on vous l'avait dit
vous vous avez supprimé le conseiller
territorial rétablit la plénitude des
effectifs des conseils généraux et des
conseils maintenant vous expliquer qu'il
faut réduire le nombre d'élus et on
risque d'avoir certains départements qui
n'auront qu'un seul conseiller régional
on sait pas qui ira assisté conseil
d'administration des lycées et des
collèges mais enfin vous avez commencé
par supprimer cette réforme et il aurait
été beaucoup plus judicieux pour le
département pour le gouvernement de la
conforter il y avait un désaccords de
fond sur le mode de scrutin et bien
adopter sur un autre passer à la
proportionnelle inscrite un mixte ça
aurait été beaucoup plus d'intelligent
et beaucoup plus en intérêt national de
conforter les collectivités
territoriales quittant changer de mode
de scrutin tout ça peut être évolutif
mais là on est dans un bouleversement
total qui crée la confusion et
certainement pas la clarification et
même dans la spécialisation des
compétences nous avions concédé à
l'opposition de l'époque devenue
majorité le maintien de la double
compétence dans le tourisme la culture
ou le sport et bien il fallait à ce
moment d'arriver à une spécialisation
eclaire et net quel dommage que vous
ayez manquer cette occasion donc de
conforter de compléter une réforme
beaucoup plus dans la continuité de ce
qu'avait fait tous les gouvernements
vous avez rappelé la Troisième
République la Quatrième République la
Cinquième République et bien on aurait
utilement vous auriez qu'ils m'ont
renforcé nos dispositif institutionnel
non pas par la rupture et pour refaire
finalement moins bien ce qu'on avait
commencé à faire mais on confortant et
en complétant même si comme sur le mode
de scrutin il y a des désaccords de
fonds sur la droite et la gauche mais
c'est pas ça qui aurait dû bouleverser
les collectivités locales ensuite sur le
périmètre des régions les présidents de
région eux-mêmes nous ont tous expliqués
ce que nous savions déjà c'est à dire
aujourd'hui la force des régions ne
dépendez pas de l'étendue de leur
territoire ou de leur population mais de
leurs compétences et de leurs moyens je
suis mosellan voisin de la Sarre moins
d'un million d'habitants alors que mon
département fait plus d'un million mais
quand la Sarre petit Land et pas le plus
riche par habitant consentent les moyens
du département dans la région et toute
une partie de l'État central il a
aujourd'hui une efficacité publique sans
commune mesure avec la nôtre et je
parlerai pas de notre autre voisin qui
est le Luxembourg
et c'est une vision très parisienne et
technocratique de de vouloir à tout prix
nous coller des régions comme les Landes
parce que la France c'est un territoire
deux fois plus grand que la l'Allemagne
avec une population bien moins
importante donc les régions c'est pas
que des populations
c'est aussi des territoires donc je
crois que vous vous n'allez pas vers
l'objectif qu'on veut et qu'au contraire
des très grandes régions risquent
simplement d'éloigner davantage le
citoyen du lieu de des centres de
décision ce qui est pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la
décentralisation le mouvement inverse de
un sujet qui a été suivi on est déjà
avec des mers qui ont des compétences de
plus en plus liées demain ils feront
même plus leur plus ils auront juste le
droit de signer les permis de construire
en compétence il y a de PLU qui ont été
définis plus haut n'ont pas par des élus
directs et les conseillers généraux vont
être des racines un conseiller ou de
conseiller régional pour le Cantal ou
pour d'autres députés départements vont
rompre cette proximité donc on voit
beaucoup plus le pouvoir vers la
technostructure y compris des techno
structures de collectivités
décentralisée que vraiment une une
nouvelle conquête
démocratique et c'est pas de nature à
rapprocher le citoyen du pouvoir au
moment où la montée des populismes est
de de l'abstention devrait
amener le le mouvement inverse donc le
gouvernement sera-t-il réceptif veut
dire aux amendements qui viseront tout
de même à limiter les dégâts à réduire
tout de même
à créer des régions un peu moins
absurdes là aussi pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de République et
peut-être de l'État français parce que
même sous l'Ancien Régime ça se serait
jamais produit comme ça on a quand même
eu des régions des immenses régions dont
une qui va réunir le plateau de Langres
à la Baie de Somme et l'autre La
Rochelle à Bourges qui ont été définis
en une après midi par les caprices de
cours et non pas par une réflexion
approfondie alors je crois monsieur le
ministre que l'espère que le Sénat
pourrait s'exprimer dans toute sa
sagesse pour retravailler cette
cartographie et si vous voulez vraiment
vous tenez absolument des grandes
régions et que vous voulez des régions
pertinentes je vois pas en quoi le fait
de d'éventuellement séparer un
département de sa région d'origine
serait un tabou absolu qui serait
absolument viable si vous voulez
vraiment cet exercice de rentre de
grande région permettez-nous de le faire
pour aboutir aux résultats le plus
pertinent et je m'arrête là monsieur le
président pour pas que vous me
reprochiez d'être trop long et bien je
n'ai rien dit Monsieur Grosdidier mais
peu à peu mon discours finit par
s'imprimer en vous et c'est très très
bien parce que vous le tenez vous-même
mais oui mais en fait quand même ça
progresse toujours un peu monsieur Néry
on va arriver à votre intervention mais
après avoir entendu monsieur buffet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre une observation et une petite
précision en ce qui concerne
l'observation
il s'agit effectivement des propos qui
ont été tenus tout à l'heure par les
présidents de région qui étaient
présents force est de constater que le
message qui résulte de leur
interventions est
la taille à peu d'importance finalement
ce qui compte c'est la puissance du
territoire et par delà la puissance
économique puisque c'est ce qu'ils ont
dit très clairement
j'aurais souhaité en tous les cas à
titre personnel que l'on évoque pas
seulement cet aspect là des choses mais
qu'on l'on parle aussi un peu plus ou
qu'il parle plus exactement un peu plus
aménagement du territoire car il y a
vraiment sur ce point-là un sujet et en
ce qui me concerne je ne trouverai pas
totalement tabou de pouvoir franchir
quelques étapes et effectivement
remettre en cause si cela était
nécessaire les périmètres existants pour
coller réellement sur ce qui est
d'importance c'est à dire les bassins de
vie et les cohérences de territoire et
puisque vous êtes permis de citer des
citer le général de Gaulle tout à
l'heure sur les mémoires d'espoir vous
savez que je les partage grandement en
tous les cas les la philosophie
gaulliste et pour moi importante et je
crois que nous avons l'occasion ici
peut-être de franchir cette étape
d'autant plus que vous venez de nous
dire que nous aurions de lecture par
chambre donc finalement un peu de temps
donc profitons-en
la question est plus particulière elle
concerne la métropole de Lyon monsieur
le ministre vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure qu'évidemment les conseillers
généraux qui étaient élus sur le
territoire de la Communauté Urbaine
devenant métropole vers elle leur mandat
se terminer il me semble alors bien
compris le premier décembre 2015 or je
lis dans le texte qui nous avons reçu le
31 décembre 2014 donc nous sommes bien
clairs que c'est bien au 31 décembre
2014 que le mandat des conseillers
généraux actuels sur le territoire de la
métropole cesseront d'accord ok donc
merci
on a entendu avec enfin bon je vais pas
mettre en difficulté ma voisine mais on
avait entendu premier décembre 2015 pour
ça d'accord bon merci c'est clair vous
en avez terminé monsieur buffet oui
merci Monsieur buffet Monsieur Alain
Neri oui merci monsieur le Président moi
pour dire que en tant que sénateur du
Puy-de-Dôme et
habitant de la région Auvergne je me
réjouis de notre rapprochement avec la
région Rhône-Alpes
parce que elles correspond pour un grand
nombre de nos départements à un bassin
de vie et un bassin de développement
depuis longtemps les gens de la
Haute-Loire sont tournés du côté de
Saint-Étienne de Lyon les gens du
Puy-de-Dôme vont régulièrement à
Saint-Etienne ou à Lyon et ont de
relation les gens Vichy et de sont très
près de Roanne et donc de la région
Rhône-Alpes etc il y a peut-être un
petit souci pour nos amis du Cantal mais
il s'expriment pour dire s'ils ont des
soucis voilà mais il y a un souci que
j'ai monsieur le ministre c'est que
quand je vois la représentation des
différents départements dans les
nouvelles régions je constate que la
représentation de nos départements est
sérieusement à Moinerie puisque
aujourd'hui nous avons 22 conseillers
régionaux dans le département du
Puy-de-Dôme et que sur la grille qu'il
les fourni il y en a 14
potentiels mais qui ne seront pas 14
puisque lorsque je vais le total de la
liste qui est dans votre projet de loi
j'arrive pour le pour la région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes à 176 conseillers régionaux
alors que nous sommes limités à 150 donc
moi je suis attaché à l'égalité de
traitement entre les régions et entre
nos concitoyens
j'ai pas partagé le découpage des
circonscriptions législatives pour les
députés
puisque nous avions là je crois ceux qui
aujourd'hui veut nous donner des leçons
sur le découpage ferait bien de se
rappeler du charcutage auquel se soit
livrées les ministres du gouvernement
précédent et qui était au-delà du
raisonnable car on a des départements où
les circonscriptions qui ont été faites
ne correspondent nullement à aucune
réalité ni géographique ni économique ni
de Bassani donc vous coûter monsieur le
ministre vous connaissez bien le
département de la Manche je crois de la
façon dont on était découper
circonscriptions je parlais pas de celle
du Puy-de-Dôme parce que là je serai
parti prenante c'est vraiment faire
preuve de beaucoup d'imagination et de
beaucoup d'incohérence bien
mais il y a une chose qui paraissait
intéressante c'est à partir du moment on
disait un député représente
un certain nombre d'habitants à peu près
000 101.000 moi je serai assez partisan
puis le ministre qu'on mette dans nos
villes commettent dans nos
dans nos critères pour déterminer le
nombre de conseillers régionaux une
représentation par habitant qu'un
conseiller régional représente un
certain nombre d'habitants avec ce qui a
été fait dans certains cas peut-être un
nombre minimum et un nombre maximum un
plancher et un plafond je m'explique
pourquoi un plan un plafond parce que on
aurait des départements très peuplés qui
arriverait peut-être à écraser les
autres mais dans les dépôts les petits
départements nous risquons d'avoir quand
même quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire ce ministre
je veux pas citer de département pour
faire telle personne mais vu la
répartition et après avoir fait quelques
simulations puisque la répartition se
fera selon les règles précédentes nous
avons des départements tout petits qui
rend un représentant
un représentant et bien celui qui aura
un représentant il a déjà un seul député
il a déjà un seul sénateur c'est à dire
que pour présenter la même
circonscription le département vous
aurez trois
trois élus différents avec la même
circonscription t des fois il est assez
difficile de faire cohabiter
deux ou trois caïmans dans le même
marigot là je crois qu'on prendrait
quelques difficultés supplémentaires
d'autant plus que nous aurions un député
qui lui est élu au suffrage universel
direct et un sénateur qui a un
collectoral différent ce qui peut
permettre une cohabitation mais entre le
cancer régional qui sera tout seul et le
député qui sera tout seul ils auront le
même territoire et le même corps
électoral je me pose quelques problèmes
sur la cohabitation entre
voilà à moins que à moins qu'on
rétablisse le cumule non mais ça c'est
monsieur katenbach qui le dit c'est pas
moi donc je souhaiterais que au niveau
de la représentation on détermine un
plancher et un plafond peut-être avec un
minimum qui pourrait être de 2 ou 2 3
pour que effectivement il y a une
représentation des petits départements
qui soient convenables et en limitant au
maximum mais en disant chaque conseiller
régional doit représenter partout en
France un nombre x d'habitants et
deuxième chose et puis je m'arrêterai là
monsieur le Président je vais mouliner
très vite je vais changer de braquet
pour vous dire tout simplement qu'il y a
une question qui me paraît fondamentale
c'est l'autonomie financière des régions
parce que moi c'est pas tellement le
puissance ce qui m'intéresse c'est
l'autonomie parce que l'autonomie
financière c'est la liberté et moi je
suis toujours sur les règles qui ont
présidé à la décentralisation que nous
avons mis en place en 1982 et que la loi
du 2 mars 1982 rappelle que c'est la loi
bien sûr de faire mon roi mais elle
s'inscrit dans notre législation comme
la loi du 2 mars 82 relative au droit et
liberté des communes départements et
régions les droits et